بعد هذا الانتظار الطويل انني مسرور
لوجودكم معنا ويؤسفنا لابقائكم منتظرين
لفتره من زمن سوف نبدا برئيسي المجلس
السيد عبد العزيز ال سعود
بالاضافه الى قائمه من الوزراء الاخرين
الذين يمثلون
منظمه اوبك بلس للبدء في هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي
لا تزال لا زلنا في فتره ما بعد الظهيره
وامل اننا قد زودناكم بما يكفي من الاثاره
فهذا الجهد لم يذهب عبثا ولا اعلم اذا ما
كنتم قد رايتم هواتفكم المتحركه
فلابد لكم انكم ان رايتم تصريحات مختلفه
فاحداها ترتبط باتفاق
وقد شرعنا به بشان ما سوف نفعله في العام
2024 وما بعد ذلك
وتصريحات اخرى تتعلق
بينما تم الاتفاق به بصوره فرديه
وما سوف يتم تنفيذه كما فعلنا
في شهر ابريل حيث الدول
التي
وافقت على الخفض الطوعي
وعملت على تمديد هذا الخفض التوعي حتى
نهايه 2024
ولابد
لابد لي ان اسميها
توجه سعودي التي ايضا بدات بتخفيض
منذ مطلع يوليو بواقع 500 الف برميل ما تم
تحقيقه ايضا انجاز للقول انه لا بد لنا ان
نشرك اصدقائنا هنا
لانه ليس اولئك الذين يجلسون على يمين
ويسار في هذه القاعه هنا في اوبك بلس بل
حكوماتهم
قد قاموا باتخاذ الخيارات الصحيحه ووجهوها
الى المسار الصحيح
وخاصه في ظل هذا الاتفاق غير المسبوق
الذي
يدفعنا لطرح الاسئله الصعبه كيف لنا ان
نتوصل الاتفاق من شانه
ان يخلق المزيد من الوضوح الى الاسواق
والمزيد من الشفافيه
والمزيد من الانصاف والعداله
اتفاقات مستقله
عن
ما ندعي به وعن قراءاتنا وبصرف النظر عن
طبيعه تلك المزاعم
وهذه هي المره الاولى
التي نقر بها بحقيقه
امر يتعلق بالانتاج الشهري فقد قمنا
باعاده التاكيد بالتزامنا
من ان يتم ذلك من مصادر مستقله والان
نتخذ ناخذ مساحه اضافيه اخرى
من خلال
ما سوف تقوم به مؤسسات مستقله للتحقق من
القدره
ونعمل ما نامله ان هذه العمليه برمتها كما
تعلمون سوف تكونوا ذات طبيعه تقنيه وانها
سوف تكون مستقله عما ندعي به او عن
طموحاتنا وتطلعاتنا
او
للعمل كما تقوم به بعض الجهات مثل
الامانه العامه
وغيرها في مساله التحقق من هذه الارقام
وهذا امر منصف
الوسائل الاعلاميه والخبراء والمحللون
لطالما كانوا
يختلفون اذا ما كانت هذه الارقام مخصصه
هنا او هناك مما يدفعوا لحاله من الارباك
رغم ان الامر لم يكن مقصودا لكننا
سوف نعمل
بكل تاكيد لنتحقق بانهم سوف سوف تقراون
هذه الارقام وتطلعون عليها عندما يتم
التوصل الى تاكيد
فقد استمرينا في هذه الممر ممارسه ممارسه
الاستمراريه
في كيفيه
القدره على الوثوق بهذه المصادر الثانويه
ووفائها بالتزاماتها لذا
انه يوم عظيم بالنسبه لنا لان جوده
الاتفاق
هي جوده غير مسبوقه
ولابد لي ان اقول ان نوعيه التعاون غير
مسبوق
فلننظر الى الجزئيات التي سوف تنبثق
عن
كافه الاطراف
برمتها دون ان نختار احد بعينه
لكن حتى هذا الاجتماع كان غير مسبوق مع
كافه الاحترام
لكم جميعا
فانتم لم يكن لديكم اي فكره عما كنا
نتداوله وما كنا نناقشه وطبيعه طموحاتنا
ويمكنكم ان تروا بان طموح كان اكبر ووثيقه
الصله واكثر اهميه
فالامر برمته يعتمد على الاتجاه
لمسار يتسم بالمزيد من الشفافيه والوضوح
بالنسبه لهذا القطاع
ولهؤلاء
المنخرطين في ذلك السوق لكننا
مستمرون في ضرب
المثل عندما يتعلق الامر بالشفافيه
من اجل تحقيق
الاولويات ذات الاهميه الا وهي تحقيق
الاستدامه
والامن
ما من امر اكثر واهميه من هذه الشفافيه
فهذه وصفه
ولابد للناس ان يتسموا بوضوح نواياهم
ومعرفه التاكيدات التي سوف تكون عليها
فيما يتعلق بالمسؤوليتها شكرا مره اخرى
على وجودكم هنا سوف نكون تحت تصرفكم لاي
اسئله والان احيل الكلمه لزملائي ان كان
لديهم اي تعليقات اخرى
شكرا جزيلا
يسعدني ان اكون هنا
خاصه في اننا امضينا هذه الايام الثلاثه
الاخيره معا
رغم نفادي صبري البعض منكم
بغيت معرفه النتائج
لكن
هناك مساله تجدر بي ان اذكرها بصفه قادم
جديد الى
وهو مستوى المسؤوليه لتقديم الوضوح
للاسواق وهذه مسؤوليه عظيمه ومخاوف كبيره
للتحقق من ان الاسواق سوف تستمر في حاله
من الاستقرار
في عقب هذه الجلسه
من خلال ما قمنا به هذه السنه من اعمال
التحفيظ الطوعيه التي سوف تستمر الى نهايه
2024 فقد اتفقنا على المستويات الجديده
واصولا الى
2025 حيث اتفقنا
على رسم الارضيه او رسمي الطريق الممهد
الذي سوف ياخذنا الى المزيد من الوضوح
والاستقرار حول كيفيه
الوصول
لمستويات الخفض التوعيه هذه لذول مختلفه
التهانينا لاوبك بلس
وعلى التحلي بروح المسؤوليه
شكرا اصحاب السعاده
اعتقد انه اصاله عن نفسي لا بد لي ان اشكر
صاحب السمو الملكي
وكافه الوزراء الاخرين الذين عملوا بلا
كلل وملل
سنه تلو الاخرى كنا نجتمع في اجتماعات
عهده واحد تلو الاخر مما يدل على
تعاضدنا في فهم الاسواق والحقيقه باننا
متحدون عندما يتعلق الامر
في مساله استقرار الاسواق رغم كافه
التحديات فاننا نرى هذا القرار الاستثنائي
الذي يشكل خطوه مهمه في طريق تحقيق المزيد
من الشفافيه والانصاف والعداله
لمتطلبات السوق
ونحن بصفتنا كدوله الامر لدوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده انضمينا في التخفيض
الطوعي حتى العام 2024 وكما اشار سعادته
الرئيس فاننا ايضا نرسم خارطه الطريق
النظر بكافه الاشياء التي تتحدث عنها
وسائل الاعلام قد وقد لا نكون متفقين
بشانها فيما بيننا وهذا امر غير صحيح نحن
هناك دائما نتفهم ما يدور بيننا ونتفهم
متطلبات الاسواق
وهذا نضعه فوق
مصالحنا الخاصه
ونشكره هو المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
على هذه المكافاه الاخرى او تخفيض التوعي
الذي يظهر لكم جليا مدى اهميه استقرار
الاسواق ومدى اهميه
طرح الاستثمارات في هذا القطاع المهم اننا
بحاجه لاستثمارات لضمان انه على المدى
الطويل
سوف
نفي بمطالب العالم فنحن نعيش في مرحله
انتقاليه في مجال الطاقه وتلك المرحله
تقضي علينا ان يكون لدينا المستوى المناسب
من الانتاج وان يكون بالمتناول للسنوات
المقبله ومن اجل حدوث ذلك لابد لنا من جذب
مستثمرين للاستمرار
في الاستثمار والبعض منا
يعملون على ذلك واخرون لابد من حثهم
وتشجيعهم على الوصول الى البيئه المئاتيه
لذا اود ان اهنئ الفريق
ونشكر كل واحد منهم هنا
والغائب منهم على فهمهم وعلى دعمهم
لقرارنا
انا من شرور انه اكون هذا اليوم
في هذا الاجتماع المبارك مع الاخوه في
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه كانت يعني
لن نتردد
[موسيقى]
باننا كمنظمه اوبك سوف لن نتردد باتخاذ
والمستهلكين
والمستثمرين
كدوله دوله العراق
تعتبر من الدول المؤسسه لمنظمه اوبل
لتاسيس هذه المنظمه التي تاسست في بغداد
في بغداد
وعاصمه العراق ان شاء الله
تمديد التاثير الضوئي لغايه 24 اضافه الى
موافقتنا ان شاء الله على كل القرارات
[موسيقى]
سمو الملكي اصحاب السعاده السيداتي سيدتي
لابد لي ان اقول بان زميلي قد حصل على
دوره مكثفه نعم هذين هذان اليومان
الاجرين اجتماعات مكثفه خلالهما وكل ما
يبدا بصوره جيده سوف يثمر بنتائج طيبه
حتى نهايه العام 2024 لذا فان القضاء هذا
الوقت في الاجتماع كان يستحق تلك الجهود
اشكركم مره اخرى على هذا الاجتماع المثمر
شكرا صاحب السمو الملكي
اصعب اسعد الله اوقاتكم
يسعدني ان اكون جزءا من هذا الاجتماع واود
ان اشكر الجميع على المناقشات التي
اظهروها وعلى سعه صدرهم
وعلى الاجابه على وسوف نترك الاجابه على
الاسئله حتى نهايه المؤتمر الصحفي
بصفته
وزير النفط بالوكاله في الكويت
وكدوله عضو في فكنت اعمل مع الزملاء
بالنظر في التطورات التي تجري في الاسواق
بالاضافه الى مستويات الانتاج كان من
الضروره بمكان للجميع بما في ذلك الكويت
الضمان الضمان الامتثال
بمبادئ اوبك وكنت سعيد للغايه
بما اثمر عنه الاجتماع كما اشار صاحب
السمو الملكي الامير عبد العزيز بان
الخفض الطاوعي سوف يتم تمديده حتى نهايه
واشعر بالسعاده لرؤيه تلك الاليه التي تم
تطبيقها من اجل
اطفائي المزيد من الضبابيه والاستقرار في
الاسواق من خلال
وجودي اطراف مستقله لاجراء عمليات التقييم
على مستويات الانتاج هذه هي مداخلتي اود
ان اشكر الجميع
صاحب السمو الملكيه على اعطاء الكلمه
ومره اخرى مره اخرى اود
ان اثني على كافه
الوزراء الذين مثلوا في اجتماعنا اليوم
كما ذكر من قبل
لقد كانت ايام
مليئه بالعمل الدؤوب
لكننا مسؤولون في نهايه الامر عما يحدث في
الاسواق
والضمان الاستقرار والان نسعى لتحقيق
المزيد من هذا الاستقرار لانه لدينا
الادوات
التي يمكننا من خلالها ان نعمل على خلق
المزيد من الرؤيه والشفافيه وحتى كافه
الدول
التي تتخذ هذه القرارات قد تكون صعبه
احيانا لكنها التزمت بالكامل
على تنفيذ
ما تبنيناه
بالنسبه
للخفض الضوئي حتى العام
من العام 2023 حتى
نهايه العام 2014
وبالنسبه لنا سوف نفعل قصار جهدنا باننا
سوف
نلتزم في هذا
التخفيض
عند هيثم ان كان لك ان تدير
الاشخاص الذين يرغبون بطرح اسئله
سواء كانت الاسئله موجهه لي او لزملائي
شكرا جزيلا يا له من اتفاق كنت اود ان
اسال عندما يتعلق في النصف المتبقي من هذه
السنه بالنسبه للسعوديه كيف ترون الاسواق
حتى نهايه نهايه هذا العام
وما هي التطلعات او توقعات المستقبليه
بالنسبه للسنوات المقبل
بالنسبه
يمكنك ان تطرح هذا السؤال
على اي من الزملاء في اوبك بلس ونحن لا
نكشف
اسرارا عما نقوم به لكن نتوقع بان هذه
الخطوات التي اخذناها سوف تكلل بالنجاح
هذه الممارسه اللي طالما بدانا بها
وتمرسنا بها منذ العام 2020
من خلال العمل مع زملائنا في الامارات
وعمان ومن ثم طبقنا تلك الممارسه مجددا في
العام 2021
وكنا دائما نرغب
بان
نضمن بان العالم سوف يعرفون ما هي الاشياء
التي نقوم بها هذا جزء مما نقوم به بصوره
شهريه وكما اسلفت الذكر
المساله قابله للتمديد اود ان
اود ان اعلم
ان اعلم كيف سوف يقرؤون طريقه التفكيرنا
وما سوف نعتف على فعل هذا خيارهم
لكن لا تقولوا ان اي تجربه سابقه لا تقول
ان اي تجربه سوف تشكل سابقا
لكن بالنسبه لكافه الزملائي اود ان اعيد
واشدد باننا نحن كمجموعه من 23 دوله سوف
نفعل ما هو ضروري لتحقيق الاستقرار في هذا
السوق
ما هو ضروري
ناصر الطيبي العربيه تي في
اوقاتكم صاحب السمو الملكي اصحاب السعاده
صاحب سمو الملكي
ما الذي
يعنيه الخفض الطوعي في العام 2004 بالنسبه
للاساسيات في الاقتصاد بالنسبه
لهذه المجموعه السعوديه هل هذا سوف يبقي
المستثمرين في حاله من التكهل دعني اجيب
على المجموعه على الجزئيه الاخيره من
السؤال
بعض الناس لا يصورون لما لما اقوله من
البدايه حتى النهايه
قد يكون لديهم طريقه في انتقائه بعض
المفردات والكلمات التي تروخ لهم لكن ما
ذكرته في الدوحه
قلت بان هناك بعض التكهن وهذا جزء من كل
سوء لذا افضل
من الناس ان ترى بام عينها
قد سماه البعض بان
باننا نقوم بتكهنات هذه ليست بمزحه هذه
سوق تخص
وتلامس حياه ملايين من البشر الذين
يعتمدون بصوره كليه على وجود سوق مستقره
الناس قد ترغب
بان ترمي ببعض النكات هنا وهناك لا غير في
ذلك لكننا هنا نفعل
كل ما يلزم لتحقيق
الوضوح وهذا الاجراء لا يتخذ من قبلنا
فحسب حتى بل انه يتخذ من قبل اصدقائنا اذا
كان ضروريا
قد يتفق قد يختلف البعض مع الانجليزمان
عندما قال بانه بانني سوف اقوم بتسجيل
الامر الى ما كل هو ضروري او بالنسبه
للجزء الاول فنحن لم نقول في ابريل
الامر بانه من باب الاحتياط او كاجراء
احتياطي
فنحن نقوم بتلمس الحدث
بهذه هي الاساسيه وسوف نستمر في هذا
التوجه طالما اننا لا نرى اي وضوح او
استقرار
هو احسب ان تلك هي
الممارسه
التي يقوم بها اي وزير سواء في قطاع
التعدين او في الطاقه الفرق باننا نهتم
بكافه التفاصيل لكن بالنسبه لبعض السلع
الاخرى
فقد تكون الامور حتى بالنسبه لهم مختلفه
عما حدث في عام 2022 القبيله المبادرات
الاستباقيه وحضورنا وانتباهنا الاسواق قد
يكون هو اهم من اي شيء اخر
[موسيقى]
لملايين مواطنين دول اوبك
والدول الاخرى اللي ليست
اوبيك بلس ولا حتى الصناعه هذا قرار يساعد
على يعني تعزيز فرص استقرار الاسواق ومنعه
من التذبذب الحاد والتذبذب بالحاد ياخذ من
ناحيتين نشف فقط الى الاسفل ولكن هي ايضا
الى الاعلى نعتقد ان هذه الاجراءات هي
الاجراءات التي يجب ان نتصرف اننا ناخذها
كمنتجين مسؤولين عن
مره اخرى نريد ان نثبت العالم انه نحن
نعمل
كبنوك مركزيه فعليه ناضجه تملك الادوات
والوسائل اللي تعزز من انها تمارس هذا
الدور
بفاعليه وبمهنيه
وقادره على انها تحقق هذا الاستقرار
المطلوب
عندي يعني عشان ضيق الوقت
الامين العام اصحاب السعاده شكرا لكم
جزيلا صاحب سمو الملكي
ووزير الخارجيه مقرر ان يتجه الى السعوديه
في الاسبوع المقبل
اتعجب ما هي المحادثات التي اجريتموها مع
بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين وكيف تتوقعون
الردود افعال المسؤولين في امريكا حاول
بشان هذا التخفيض ثانيا فيما يتعلق بمساله
شفافيه التي تطرقتم لها اليوم
قد اكون محظوظا لطرح سؤال في المؤتمر
الصحفي كذلك زملائي الاخرين هل لك ان تشرح
لنا بمزيد من الاسهاب حول هذا القرار الذي
تم اتخاذه اليوم
السؤال الاول
الوزير بلنكن
وكل مسؤول امريكي وكذلك ايضا اي مواطن
امريكي كلهم موضعه ترحيب في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وهذا ليس الا جزءا من علاقاتنا الثنائيه
التي مر عليها ثمانيه عقود من الزمن
ويتم احيائها باستمرار وسوف تستمر على هذا
المنوال واننا نتطلع لمزيد من التعاون
لكننا نشعر ببعض القلق من ان يشعر البعض
بالغيره
اما بالنسبه لسؤالك الثاني فهذا فهذه
مساله تنظيميه هو الشخص المناسب الذي يجب
ان تطرح عليه سؤال هو
هو او هي الامانه العمل اذا لن اتطرق
للاجابه عليه
شكرا بصوره اساسيه
الامانه العامه لطالما كانت مفتوحه
والدليل على ذلك هو وجودي وكالات اخباريه
واعلاميه من كافه المناطق العالم من
الشمال والشرق والجنوب ولدينا مجموعه من
بعض الدول
الاعضاء في اوبرك فهذه دعوه مفتوحه ولدينا
اكثر من 150 شخصا قد توجهت لهم دعوه
لتغطيه هذا الحدث وكذلك وجهنا دعوات
لوسائل اعلاميه في الخارج
لهذا المؤتمر لدينا دائما سياسه مفتوحه
شفافه
ولكل شخص
عن ان يتلمس بنفسه بما تقوم به منظمتنا
بفتح ابوابها
كافه الوسائل الاعلاميه لحضور هذه
الاجتماع هذه هي طريقتنا وهذه هي الطريقه
التي ننفذ بها استراتيجيهنا من خلال توجيه
دعوات للوسائل الاعلاميه
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا الامين العام وشكرا على دعوتنا
اليوم من المؤكد ان هذه الاتفاقيه الشامله
فيما يتعلق مع
تحفيظ وتخفيض التوعي السؤال الذي اود ان
اطرحه هو عن الاستثناء فهناك مجموعه من
الدول التي سوف تبقى خارج هذا الاتفاق بل
بعض منها كانوا قد البعض منها قد عملت على
زياده الانتاج والباطره ان الوضع يدفع
للسقرار اود ان اسال عن الاجراءات المتبعه
بخصوص الدول المستقبله لان ان نيجيريا
كانت مستثناه في السابق والان تجلس على
الطاوله كجزء منه هل لنا ان نفكر ما الذي
قد يحدث في فنزويلا وايران وليبيا في
المستقبل
النيجر كانت النيجيريا كانت مستثناه
نعم هذه السابقه لا اود تذكرها
واضحين بصوره لا لبس فيها بشان هذه الامر
فهذه ممارسه معتمده في عندما تقوم دوله
مثلا
في وضع ما مختلف
فهذا هذه طبيعتي عملنا في المنظمه
فبالنسبه لليبيا فعندما تعود
الى انتاجها الاصلي عندما بدانا هذا
الاتفاق فسوف نرحب بها لتنضم الينا وكذلك
الحال بالنسبه لايران
لكنك تعلمين
ان كلا من الدولتين
لا تزالان تعيشان في ظروف مختلفه فيما
يتعلق
في انتاج مبال كميات كبيره من الناظر
[موسيقى]
امينه بكر انرجي
شكرا جزيلا صاحب السمو الملكي اصحاب
السعاده وتهانينا على هذا الاتفاق الشامل
اليوم اود ان اسال معا كيف يمكن لهذا
الاتفاق ان يساعد في تقلبات الاسواق راينا
التخفيضات السابقه ومع ذلك بقيه الاسواق
متقلبه فيما يتعلق بالاسعار اود ان اسالك
سؤال هل تهدفون الى مدى محدد لانه اعلم
انه قد يكون من الجراه تم طرح هذا السؤال
سوف اعطيك نفس الجواب
ليس فقط جوابي لكن حتى كافه
من سبقني في هذا المنصب كانوا يعطونك
محاضره كامله يشرحون لك ليش يشرحون لك
كيفيه
الامور
وهذا
لم نعد
بمقدورنا وفعل ذلك لان هذا قد لا يحقق
دائما
وهذا درس
تعلمناه منذ تمنيات القرن الماضي ومطلع
التسعينيات
واي شخص
لديه
المنطق في معرفه طبيعه هذا السوق فانه قد
يوافقني في هذا التوجه
سؤال سؤالك حول التقلبات في الاسواق
رايت بعض التعليقات الساخره هنا وهناك حول
التقلب التقلب لديها جانبا
كدوله منتجه منذ عهد طويل فنحن لا نود
التقلبات قصيره متوسطه او طويله الامد
فراينا ما الذي فعلته الاسعار المنخفضه
للقطاعات المختلفه والصناعات وكيف اثرت
ايضا
ارتفاعها
وراينا ما الذي فعلته في حاله ارتفاعات
ارتفاعها على القطاعات
وكذلك اثرت على
على وزائر على وزارات
الماليه
ووزاره التخطيط التي بات عليها ان ترسم
توقعات
التي سرعانا ما تختلف عليهم ويدفعهم
لاتخاذ خيارات مختلفه
اي شخص منطقي
لابد له ان يتاكد من طبيعه هذه التقلبات
وما معناها فهي لا تحمل وجها واحد بل
وجهان ونحن نركز على كافه الجوانب فنحن
الان نود
التقلبات قصيره او متوسطه الامل وبكل
تاكيد لا نود
حدوث تقلبات طويله الامد
جميع من ميس شكرا صاحب سمو الملكي فلنعد
عن التخفيض الطاوعي في يوليو هل لك ان
تعطينا مدى مدى سوف يتم
اطلاق اعلان بشان
الاشهر المقبله كيف يمكن الاسواق ان تتوقع
مده الاشعار
بشان التخفيض
لقد فعلنا هذا الامر سابقا في عام 2021
لماذا
نحرم ههه انفسنا من حق ابقاء الناس في
حاله من الشك
فالحكومه السعوديه
كلفتني بهذه المهمه
على ارقام شهر مايو
كيف ترون سوف تكون عليه اوضاعها في هذه
السنه وفي السنه المقبله على خلفيه
الاتفاق الذي توصلتم اليه
في شهر ابريل هذا ما سوف يتم العمل به
بالمصادر الثانويه
او الموارد الثانويه المعذره
اما فيما يخص
توقعاتي الجميع فنحن لا توجد فانا لا توجد
لدي توقعاتي الخاصه
ولا يوجد لدينا هذا التحيز
فنحن ننظر الى المسار العام كلنا نفعل ذلك
في بلاس وكما قلت في اكثر من مره فنحن
كمجموعه متكامله نعمل على رسم التوقعات
المستقبليه
هو ليس من باب العيب ان نخطئ في توقعاتنا
لان الاشياء تتغير والاشياء تحدث
لدى
لا يوجد
علم مثبت
ومسند بهذا الامر
فانا لا انظر الى التوقعاتك واحده من
الاشياء التي يجب ان تكون
مصدرا موثوقا لانه
قد تاتي انت وتنافسيني في توقعات
شكرا صاحب سمو الملكيين اهنئكم على هذا
الاتفاق
انا لا انظر الى التفاصيل انظروا الى جدول
الانتاج فمثلا ارى ان الامارات العربيه
المتحده كان
انتاجها اعلى بمئتي الف ما الذي يعني هذا
بالنسبه لها في السنه المقبله
هناك حاله من الشفافيه
ارى دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده ان
المساء الانتاج كان اعلى في ب 200,000
بمائه الف برميل ما الذي قد يعني ذلك
واعلم انه حتى نهايه 2024 او حتى تكونوا
مسافه كبيره ان كان لي ان اجيب على السؤال
نعم
تمت تعديل قد جرى على الانتاج في دوله
الامارات
وهذا ليس امرا خفيا بان القدره الانتاجيه
سوف تنخفض
وقد تم رفعها من قبل
والمجموعه دعم الامارات
اصبحت
اكثر قربا بمئتي البرميل
هذه طريقه الامارات
للنظر
بتلك البرامج التي لم يتم انتاجها
والفارق لا يزال كبيرا لكن ما ذكرناه بانه
لدينا خارطه طريق حتى 2025
الى بريتد
الطريق هذه سوف يتم دراسه كافه التفاصيلها
في مرحله لاحقه لكننا بصدد
العمل باليه تتسم بالشفافيه فيما يتعلق
بقدره انتاج كل بلد بطريقه منصفه
[موسيقى]
والنظر
بطريقه
الانتاج باثر رجعي بالنسبه لكل دوله البعض
منها قد يتراجع
وهذه الاتفاقيه الشامله اخذت في الاعتبار
بعض المخاوف
التي
تسود بالنسبه لبعض دول اود ان اشكر
المجموعه على اقرارها عن نقص
الذي جرى في قدره
الانتاج الفعلي لدوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده الامارات سوف تدعم هذه المجموعه
على الدوام
وسوف نعمل معا
ومن خلال اثاره الطريق التي تحدث عنها
رئيس المؤتمر
صاحب السعاده
سوف
ندرس تفاصيل خارطه الطريق بالنسبه
على من اجل التوصل الى الشفافيه والانصاف
لكافه الدول سؤال من
[موسيقى]
صاحب السمو الملكي اصحاب السعاده تهانينا
على هذه الاتفاق الشامل سؤالي لصاحب سموه
الملكي فيما يتعلق بالاستثمار في هذا
القطع اذا ما استمر الاستثمار في الانخفاض
على المدى القصير هل سوف يكون هناك اي
تاكيد حول الحد الادنى
للاستثمارات من كل بلد
اذا ما نظرت الى هذه الاتفاقيه فانه سوف
يتم اجراء
بعض التقييمات المقيبه للدول بعينها
حفر نوفمبر قبل استماعنا المرتقب في شهر
نوفمبر لكن في العام 2005 في العام 2024
سوف نعمل كلنا
على اجراء تقييم
من قبل تلك المؤسسات المستقله
وذلك الاستعراض سوف يتم قبل العام 2024
وقد يتم الانتقاء والاختيار لكنكم سوف
تلاحظون ان هذه الاتفاقيه
ترسم الحدود الدنيا
وفي ظل معرفتنا للوقت القصير المتبقي لنا
فاننا ممتنونا لنيجيريا وانغولا والكونغو
على موافقتهم لاجراء هذا التقييم والتاكدي
بانه اي ارقام
تتوفر لدينا في في ظل هذه الاتفاقيه
الحاليه
سوف
يتم
النظر بها في العام 2024 وقد عبرت كل
منهما على
رغبتهما في تراس
الجلسات والالتزام
بمعرفه التقييم والمخاطر
التي قد تنبثق عن ذلك لذا فانها فانه قد
يكون امر امرا منصفا للجميع في عام 2004
ودعوني اتطرق لمساله
روسيا
اعلم
انهم قد تحدثوا
مع انرجي انتلجنس
ولا اعلم اذا ما كان هيرمان موجوده
وتحدثوا الى بلاس
عندي
وقدمت التزاما بان اي اعاده تقييما
تتعلق بهذه المصادر بهذه الموارد المستقله
التي سوف تطبق في يونيو لكنها سوف تتفق مع
ما توجهت عليه السعوديه
واذا كان
للمجموعه كهيئه محل تعطي ارقاما اضافيه او
او ارقام اقل ويمكن ان يحدث ذلك
فسوف نقبل منهم ان يستمروا
في مساهمتهم بالخفض الطوعي
شكرا في
ان اطلب من زملائي في نيجيريا وكونغو ان
كان يرغبان ايطاليا
الملكي السيدات سادتي اعتقد انه
[موسيقى]
لدينا التقييم واقعي للغايات اذا ما نظرنا
الى
القدره على الانتاجيه لكل دوله
بمفردها والتحديات التي قد يصعب التعامل
معها في الاوقات الاخيره وهي مساله لن
اكررها الان
لكن مدى الشفافيه
والشموليه في الخطوات التي تم اتخاذها
وفي حجم التقييم التي بدت
بداناها مع مكانزي
كانت
تتعلق بالانتاج الفعلي وهذا كان يمس
الارقام الحقيقيه وهذا لا يعني انه قد تم
تخفيضها
سوف نعمل نرى كيف يمكننا ان نعمل في الربع
الاخير
في نهايه حيث سوف يتم التقييم من قبل جهه
مستقله ونعتمد نرى بان هذه النقاط تتسم
بالشفافيه بما فيه الكفايه
صاحب السمو الملكيه شكرا جزيلا
قد يكون من الضروره
ان نشرح
ما سوف تقوم به تلك الدول ثلاث
سوف نقوم باجراء تقييم قبل نهايه العام
لضمان
الوفاء بالتزامات التي تم الاتفاق عليه
في حقيقه الامر لدينا ثلاث
ازمات في العالم التي اثرت على بلداننا
الازمه الاقتصاديه هو الازمه الماليه
بسبب كوفي 19
ومن تم
الاستثمارات في هذا القطع على مر سنوات
الثلاثه الماضيه التي راينا فيها هذه
الحاله
فيها تقلبات في النمو الاقتصادي في ظل تلك
الازمات
فاننا نقضي جل وقتنا
لاعاده الاستثمارات الى بلدنا
والهدف قد يكون هو زياده الانتاج
وهذا الامر يرتبط بشده بما يحدث بالاسواق
وكما قلتم
فاماما احد قد يعود للاستثمار
على
خلفيه قيمنا في
اتخاذ القرارات في دول اوبك بلس ومجموعه
الدول في اوبر لذا فاننا جادون بشان ما
نقوم به هنا وهذه واحده من الشروط المهمه
لاعاده الاستثمارات الى بلادنا ومن خلال
هذا القيام نعتقد اننا سوف نقوم
بخلق
الظروف المؤتيه
التي تساعد على ذلك لكن لابد من اجراء
وجود تقييم معتمد
بطريقه مشفافه وبطريقه
تتم من قبل مؤسسات
مستقله وهذا ما توصلنا اليه
اتفاق وسوف نعمل على انهاء اذا قبل نهايه
العام الحالي للضمان الوفائي بالاهداف
التي تم الاتفاق عليها فيما بيننا السنه
المقبله ومن بعدها هذا امر جيد وفي ذات
الوقت فان كافه الارقام
سوف نقوم بتطبيقها والنظر بها في العام
المقبل ايضا ان الحصول على معلومات بنفس
الطريقه
ونفس المؤسسات التي سوف تقوم بذلك وبناء
على النتائج سوف يتسنى لنا القول انني سوف
اكون قادرا على تخفيض كذا وكذا هذه
الطريقه الاكثر شفافيه التي يمكن من
خلالها
اطلاعكم حول ما نقوم به والالتزامات التي
نقدمها
وكيفيه تعطينا معها بصوره جاده
لقد
اصبحت الساعه الثامنه الان والبعض منا
لابد له ان يسافر الى موطنه وهو لدينا
احاطه
هل لنا ان ناخذ سؤال يوسف
السؤال الاخير صاحب سموه الملكيه
تهانينا على هذا الاتفاق لكم ولاصحاب
السعاده في العام 2024 فان المصارف
المركزيه ما زالت مستمره في رفع اسعار
الفائده مما دفع بعجله التضخم
يمكن كانت تتحدث في السابق المصرف
المركزيه عن نسبه اثنين في المئه لكن هل
تخشون على بشان مستويات الامداد وقد تحمله
نتائج عمليه الخفض التوعي في عام 2014
هل تخلقون بالنسبه لاي نقص في الامدادات
في العام 2024
انا لا اخلق لطالما قلت كذلك فلو كنت
لاشعر بالقلق
فهذا ليس من شيمين
فنحن نعطي انفسنا ميزه التوقف عن القلق
والتركيز على القضايا المهمه
والا اذا ما كنا لنقلق لماذا نضيع وقتنا
اذا
مع اصدقائي الذين يجلسون جنبي الذين كلهم
يركزون على اعمالهم فهذا سوف يبرر
مساله الشعور باي قلق
يتحرك
في الاجتماعات المستقبليه
ان كان لي
لا نسمعك جيدا
ان تعطينا تفاصيل عن التخفيض الاضافي بنصف
مليون برميل ما الذي يمكن ان
نتوقعه
على الاقل اعطائي السوق فكره عما قد يحدث
وبالنسبه لروسيا
هذا جزء من التعليق
وسوف اتركك لتخمن ما الذي قد يحدث بصوره
يوميات
في حاله كان اي شخص يرغب بان يفكر مليا
هذا كان جانب من المؤتمر الصحفي
بعد القرار المهم الذي اتخذ اليوم
بتخفيض السعوديه الطوعي للانتاج بمليون
برميل وتمديد التخفيضات الاضافيه لمده عام
اضافي لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات